[Music]
ready for hot girl summer referencing
her single status after her split from
shawn mendes and the lyrics to her new
track manamore i feel like really in
touch with my emotions
plus she lives out a love island fantasy
in the music vid it's all a collab with
strome
yes this is my best self
[Applause]
[Music]
but camilla's time on the villa is a
little messy and it appears she's stuck
in a love triangle between two guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
turns out working with show me means a
lot to camilla she called this a dream
collab on instagram i'm so excited we
gotta say a lot of camilla's collabs
this year have been pretty amazing like
when she reunited with ed sheeran for
the summer anthem bom-bom
so tell me about the writing process a
little bit what was inspiring you as you
were writing this song and the story
that you wanted to tell we have this
kind of
chorus idea
about just kind of like what it's been
like
in my late teens and early 20s kind of
kind of falling in it in and out of love
and the ups and downs of that yeah and
those ups and downs may be hinting at
her breakup with ex-boyfriend shawn
mendes the two split in 2021 after
dating for two years and though it seems
there is no bad blood between the two
both of their latest records seem
inspired by the split
[Music]
sean all but confirmed his track when
you're gone is about to break up when he
dropped it back in march you don't
realize
like when you're like breaking up with
someone you like think it's the right
thing you don't realize all that that
comes after it like which is like
who do i call when i'm like in a panic
attack who do i call and i'm like
[Music]
yeah i mean when you're gone is really
about a
breakup and
i think in a lot of ways
it was just
me kind of processing
processing what it feels like to be
on my own again and processing what it
feels like to kind of learn how to cope
and be there for myself
[Music]